m
dans le cadre du projet nos pieds de
bois noir lors mis en place par le
conseil départemental
quarante élèves de l'école montessori se
sont rendus à l'espace régler à saint
denis au programme bricolage jardinage
ou encore collage des ateliers ludiques
à travers lesquels les enfants ont pu
découvrir les arbres du jardin et être
sensibilisés à la nature et à l'écologie
et le comité filière partage des valeurs
qui sont celles de l'écologie celle du
respect de l'autre
c'est une école mont est très proche de
la nature nous les enfants ont des ti
jardiner ou m'ont planté leurs graines
iront arroser leur petit jardin vert et
blanc va développer leur leurs plantes
juin rapport aux du vent qui est très
important de faire une sortie scolaire
ici
c'était en parfaite adéquation
avec vous
tout l'esprit de notre école trois
dispositifs du conseil départemental ont
animé ces ateliers la filière bois de
goyavier la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion et mascarin jardin
botanique de la réunion la filière bois
de goyavier on participe sur le projet
nous pieds de bois nous alors pour faire
découvrir aux enfants les essences de
bois et ont produit en fonction des
différentes classes
des porte graine des herbiers des cadres
végétaux pour que les enfants puissent
justement découvrir les nouvelles texane
par les nouvelles textures mais les
textures de bois ils vont effectivement
découvrir l'histoire d'une graine et
ensuite nous leur présentons la fameuse
virée dans questions qui change
régulièrement aujourd'hui c'est la
calebasse donc d'où elle vient comment
elle a grandi à quoi il sert quels sont
les utilisations possibles aussi de la
graine est ce qu'on peut la manger est
ce qu'on peut fabriquer des objets et
dans un deuxième temps étant donné que
les enfants ont fabriqué leur porte
graine
nous fabriquons l'étiquette de la peine
avec effectivement notre à notre
habitude des outils de recyclage du
carton du papier journal
on a proposé dont une petite découverte
du jardin donc avec pour les plus petits
bonds de découverte des images avec des
fruits
on a découvert aussi pour les plus
grands avec avec des formes de feuilles
on y arrive à retrouver les espèces on a
terminé par une petite plantation de
calebasse conquet les légumes lontan des
enfants tous enchantés d'avoir découvert
l'univers de la graine et de s'être
glissé quelques heures dans la peau d'un
botaniste
on a fait des points comme ça on a
poussé
après on a collé on a verni avec du
vernis à col mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien la nature le tout ce qui est
naturel bien ça pendant que les plantes
de mon école ben on a un potager j'ai
compris que les graines saf
pendant très longtemps sous serment
il fallait que je sois mieux c'est pour
contribuer parce que sinon est belle
bernard de la graine à la vie les
enfants ont pu découvrir les arbres du
jardin de l'espace raid les voyages et
dans l'histoire de la réunion et
comprendre ce que peut apporter la
richesse de son patrimoine